oh this is a little too Moody for my
taste let's spice it up a little
it looks so good oh man this is great
now I have gone through many Studio
setups over the course of my YouTube
career which is about
um 17 years like that's a really long
time to be making content so my studio
setups have gone through many many
changes the one that you're currently
looking at right now I got this space
about a year and a half ago and
everything happened so quickly like this
place was basically completely empty
like they were actually still building
it so I was able to make some changes as
I needed when I moved in it was actually
iPhone season so I was in a panic we
basically had to outfit this entire
Studio get everything together get
everything ready for shooting the new
iPhone everything in here was supposed
to be temporary we just kind of were
mixing and matching and making things
work I had overflow storage of equipment
I had so much stuff in here that I
couldn't actually move or really work so
there's been so much that has been going
on behind the scenes that I'm so hyped
because a few weeks ago I got some
packages from Apple aperture and this
really was kind of what stemmed all of
this and the fact that I really couldn't
even move around in here anymore because
there was there was no space and also
Tyler came back in town so with his help
and with these new aperture lights we
were able to just really kind of focus
and hone in on what we wanted to do
Hello friends so we have got
something really fun in today oh boy I
need a knife
yeah you bet yeah back up
[Music]
now once we got our new lights we
decided to completely start from scratch
so we moved all of the lights out we
rearranged everything and then put them
back slowly one by one and that actually
took a lot longer than I thought it was
going to
okay it's been a couple of days I
ordered some new things we've got some
new light stands some sandbags we've got
some of the modifiers for our new lights
did I say we got sandbags did I say yes
we we have sandbags this studio has been
basically kind of the same for the past
year and a half I've got a few ideas for
some things Tyler over here on the floor
also has some ideas for some things so
we're going to kind of just do a little
refresh redo the lighting redo our
cameras and we're gonna take you guys
along for the ride there's one rule in
the studio and that is do not touch
anything here don't touch the lighting
don't touch the tripod don't touch this
don't touch the overhead cam because
it's all set up perfectly so that if
nobody else is here I only have to push
a few buttons everything is set up lit
and it's perfect but today
it's getting touched it's getting
touched Jenna is probably gonna be just
like having like some sort of panic
attack and not know why because I've
yelled at her so many times for touching
and she just knows she's not even here
she's in Mexico she's gonna have no idea
what's happening but she's gonna know so
where do you think we should start we
pull everything off the rugs okay like
over here yes rearrange the desks and
the rugs and then start from scratch
[Music]
foreign
we're going to do our first little
lighting test so Tyler has this all set
up so he moved us back but used this arm
so that we would still have room to be
able to go out onto the patio here and
this will be our first little test and
see whoa oh my God that that light is so
bright
yeah
we did a lot of testing over the course
of several days it's got to me like
eating my salad
[Music]
we're gonna get rid of the Shelf
it's a look it's a vibe
oh that looks good
hmm
yeah
[Music]
those look so good I've been eating a
salad for two hours like the background
is still dark enough that you can see
all the lights this record player was
actually a Christmas gift from YouTube
it looks so good there I got my like
little YouTube button there some of my
Awards over here I love it I love it
also the chair which you guys saw the
unboxing of
access granted steel case actually sent
my sister a chair I sat in that chair
and about lost my mind so I connected
with them and they have made me a custom
pink one they didn't make it
specifically for me like that you can
actually go on the website and customize
any of the colors that you want they
have available I obviously had to choose
the pick
oh my God it's beautiful it's so
beautiful I can already see it
here it is
oh my gosh
[Music]
it's very customized oh my goodness
Maddie come here come experience
so comfortable I can't believe it my
butt's moving forward
look
like you adjusted it moves the scripture
forward how do we adjust the tension oh
this one I don't know what I'm doing
oh yeah
check that out I mean this is game
changing like look at this like I can
Lounge I can move these little arms up I
can move them in which is perfect for
gaming I feel like everything is coming
together everything's looking good top
down camera on point so I have these
little monitors right in front below the
camera so I'm able to basically film by
myself I just hit record on the top down
hit record on the front camera and it's
time to roll we're in business we
actually made a lot more room like I can
actually walk around here like before I
could not do that we also got a new
teleprompter set up here so sometimes I
do use a teleprompter if I have a lot of
notes or a lot of scripts that I need to
hit but what I mostly use this for is
doing conference calls so I'm able to
transport the person that I'm talking to
onto the iPad which then reflects into
the camera so it looks like I'm making
you know perfect eye contact with them
which is pretty incredible but by far
one of the best parts of this studio
makeover was setting up all of the
aperture lights inside of the scientist
link app it's so easy you just connect
each light over Bluetooth and then from
there you can control All of the Lights
individually or you can even create
different scenes for different setups
and it's just super easy to make
adjustments right on the fly from your
phone this is such a game changer that I
just can't believe we didn't do this
sooner so we ended up with two main sets
but we do actually have a third which is
my real life editing desk like this is
where I work this is where I edit this
is where I do everything I have just
been using the speakers that were built
into the studio monitor well Jonathan
Morrison was like Hey I want to send you
something and I'm not going to tell you
what it is I was like okay cool like I
thought it would be maybe like an iPhone
case or something oh no no no no it was
this hi so the Morrison sent me
something I don't know what it is but he
said to film my reaction so I'm gonna
unbox it I'm about to open it I got my
knife Jenna's over there for moral
support I have no idea what is inside of
here but this box is very heavy oh oh oh
I got a note okay this is the symphony
desktop which looks amazing sounds
amazing and has Mac OS keyboard volume
integration get it paired with oh my
goodness this is a gold mine okay I
think these might be speakers
oh
whoa look at this this is such a cool
unboxing experience
maybe I bring back my DJ career
this is
so exciting I cannot wait to try this
out look at all of these goodies so this
is everything that Jonathan sent so I
think for this particular setup I really
just want to get these speakers set up
so for that I'm going to use the
symphony desktop this thing looks so
awesome I even bought some speaker
stands now I'm a little concerned about
them because I don't know what they're
going to look like how they're going to
be I got them on Amazon and they had
like decent ratings click buy and this
box
is so heavy
[Music]
I'm into it so far we're gonna put these
together and we'll be right back you
notice I said we yeah okay
okay so it looks good but I definitely
thought that these stands were gonna be
taller I mean I guess that sometimes
happens when you see things online and
you're like yeah not quite matching up
but overall like I really like the look
of them and I think it's gonna work out
great because I'm gonna be sitting here
I feel like the angle I probably would
like it to be a little bit higher but I
think this is gonna work I love apogee
stuff so I'm so hyped about this
I'm gonna get this all updated and set
up and download the software and then
we're gonna test it out we've got the
controller happening you don't actually
need to use the dial to adjust the
volume you can still use the keyboard
controls and it syncs with a symphony so
this is pretty exciting so first I want
to let you guys hear what it sounds like
on the studio monitor and this is
actually a pretty good speaker system I
think on here I edit all of my videos
directly with this using these speakers
built in
[Music]
it's pretty good it's good it's good I
mean like I like editing on that because
I feel like it gives me a good General
base of like what audio is going to
sound like on most people's devices now
[Music]
oh my God
I have Goosebumps like I actually oh my
goodness that just hit me to the
freaking core that's not even all the
way up we're we're only at two
[Music]
oh my gosh
foreign
I've literally never heard speaker like
I've never heard sound sound so good oh
my this has ruined my life let's listen
to Jonathan's mag safe
[Music]
wow this is such an incredible addition
to my desk like I didn't ever think that
I really needed some good Studio
speakers and these are beyond anything
that I could have ever wished for thank
you Jonathan and apogee so as you can
see this is my editing setup and it is
such a dream I love having a vertical
monitor seeing what I might want to use
in my main timeline and then over here I
have a output of the entire video so if
I just want to you know relax and just
see my work of art but the cool thing
about this little area is this is our
third set so I can just kind of set a
camera up right here and here you go
it's still a part of this set but I can
do demos here I can test things out and
all of this is actually being run off of
my 14 inch M2 MacBook Pro which is kind
of shocking to think about this is sort
of my powered by OWC station and
honestly OWC has been pretty much my
storage solution for the past couple of
years I've got the Thunder Bay Flex here
which I'm using for all of my backup I
also have this OWC stack and this
Thunderbolt dock it's a little crazy the
fact that this is all being powered off
the little MacBook powering my entire
workflow I know I could probably be
using the Mac Studio for all of this but
there is just something about being able
to just unplug my MacBook and everything
that I was working on I can take with me
on the go
another thing that was really important
to me in the studio is to make sure our
cable management was kept as tidy as
possible because I run into things all
the time oh so we needed to make it as
safe as possible now it might not be
super pretty but everything is taped
down and it's been a while since I've
tripped or run into anything which is
really that's definitely the key factor
here overall everything is so much more
tidy there's actually a lot more space
because we did move some of the lights
back and something else that's really
exciting we have a trash can now I know
it's been a year and a half and I
haven't had a trash can it's so
ridiculous we also reorganized my gear
closet and this is actually something
that I had started doing months ago this
is where we've kind of got some overflow
gear we've got some tripods we've got
lights we've got a ton of bags this
definitely needs to be reorganized but
trust me this is way better than it was
I don't even want to show you a photo
because I'm embarrassed we also
reorganized our little audio and
charging station we've got extra
microphones gloves Sony batteries and
this is little MC Lights which is so
cool because it's this little carrying
case but it's also a charger we've got a
label maker which is very important to
me this is one of my favorite pieces of
tech extra camera bodies lenses ND
filters lens caps some extra monitors
batteries oh
Tyler you got me this for my birthday a
couple years ago we still have six
pictures left let's take one
we do have a dedicated podcast room but
that is currently under construction if
you've watched the podcast or listened
to it you already know this
is spooky
um
it's a work in progress
we have some big plans Big Ideas
hopefully we can execute probably one of
my favorite parts of my new studio is my
gaming room
foreign
[Music]
this is the vibe room I've got this
excessively large Asus monitor which I'm
so obsessed with like my desk is too
small to fit all of the stuff Road
Caster here and that's obviously
connected to this microphone actually I
love this insta360 webcam like I've been
using that to stream now originally this
was going to be editing and gaming in
one room but I loved having my editing
out here in the studio it just felt so
much more open I also love this room
because I don't really do much work in
here I kind of just come in it's super
Zen no shoot sorry oh God and it's just
like I don't know it's just it's a Vibe
it's like my toy room I just go in there
and play actually it's more like a
child's playroom but like an adult
version I'm into it
[Music]
so that's the current Studio setup I'm
so happy with it everything just feels
clean and neat and there's room to move
around so I'm hyped thank you guys so
much for coming along on this journey
over the past like 17 years many of you
have been here since the beginning some
of you are new hello hi maybe you don't
even know who I am welcome I'm glad
you're here either way and with that I'm
going to turn off the lights three two
one
oh
oh I look like I'm I'm getting
interrogated
[Music]